I am David feller this is Damien Edwards
hello and the goal um last year we had a
talk on diagnosing a stroke or issues
and we want to kind of check up this
year and dive deeper into different
specific kinds of issues you may have
skilling your internet core applications
how many of you guys have experienced a
situation before in production no one I
don't believe you okay everyone every
yeah holy awesome well I haven't we
don't we don't build ratifications we
work on the framework team we mostly see
people's applications that come through
our support channels so people are
running on a giraffe service or people
running internally Wilson has emails
going oh map isn't responding why is
that happening I will have a dev going
and dive in for a couple of days to
figure actually probably fair to say
that most apps that we do get the
privilege to see are ones that are
broken somehow yeah because they don't
call us unless there's a problem it's
not always their fault it could be the
framers fault so we kind of have learned
some things over the past few years and
we kind of want to share with you guys
yes so we spend tons of time like
looking at customer issues so what is
scale scale is not performance per se
scale I describe it as a measure of user
request connections per skill unit a
scaling it can be a machine a container
something that has actual compute
resources right so more skill means you
can handle more more of those units per
your actual skill unit and so sometimes
we have to trade off scale again for
more mass of an individual thing as well
right so quoting Scott Hanselman if you
do nothing you can scale infinitely all
right so do laughs you can do it you can
do more without less resources so it's
always good to try and do as little as
possible that's my philosophy in life
yeah there's two kinds of scaling
scaling and horizontally or scaling
outwards that's where you add more
resources so if you have like some VM of
some size on some we're adding more of
those is skilling out scaling up is
really increased against capacity or
scaling us capacity so adding more
memory to a container adding more CPU to
a container that scaling up and scaling
out it's a pretty basic so you can and
this can apply to every style of app you
can scale out your database
yeah with things like shotting
or going to something that's clustered
yeah and you can do vertol skip vertical
scale obviously but just having a bar
you serve this and then you just don't
establish you have to worry about anyone
else the problem is any money your full
person who has to manage that here's to
worry about scale so what is it your app
scale is there kind of two main themes
the first is you you did some work that
didn't clean up stuff so you have a
resource league for example a memory
leak or a file handle leak or a socket
leak or you're creating work faster than
that work can be finished so you could
think of a thing where you're you're
handling two minute requests and things
are coming in and they aren't finishing
fast enough to trust the use the CPU
resources right yeah
and the second one there is a real
reason why what we often see is my
application worked just fine works on my
machine right works on my machine worked
in production perfectly fine for six
months and then something changed like
you've got a five percent more traffic
than you did previously or some other
part of the infrastructure started
making a slightly different decision
which resulted in some impact on your
application and suddenly the exact same
application they've been running perfect
well before doesn't just start getting
slower or start having a little bit of
trouble it goes through a period of like
that's not right and then it just falls
on the floor right okay and we're gonna
see in this talk some of the things that
will why you get this nonlinear
relationship between well it seems to be
working really well and now it doesn't
work at all and you know not this slow
gradual decline all right so what
effects skill so that this isn't this is
intend to be a full list of things
they're mostly common things to look out
for in your applications so there's CPU
memory and i/o and i/o can be network or
disk so CPU you have a hot path on your
arm on your request path some expensive
algorithm leak trying to find Prime's or
trying to do my own image compression or
something like that contended lock so
you see imagine you have a some shared
resource that all requests come in to
get and as a giant look around that that
thing their memory leak so imagine you
had some cash somewhere that wasn't
bounded as an example of a leak things
that I'll came what and they have to so
imagine
to read a file from the network and you
regenerate some memory I thought that
that that scenario port exhaustion so so
imagine you weren't disposing your HTTP
clients properly you get exhausted their
mobile ports on the machine which could
lead to issues with the HP client calls
not look at your disk storage you
imagine you were actually right with the
disk and they run a space that's kind of
a example you've never had a server fail
because their disk disabled because of
logs yeah Wow it happens a lot that
common huh yeah blocking i/o is one
that's dear to our hearts yeah she's
seen my tweets about async blocking and
async void and async is terrible and
great at the same time blocking is
really bad it it causes people to be
starved and we'll see more that later in
this talk but let's see you have a fixed
mode of bandwidth in your and your
network servers if you go over that you
kind of don't you can't serve enough
requests and sometimes these things end
up being related so a problem in one
area will lead to a problem in the other
and so you might look at one of these
things ago well I have all the bandwidth
in the world is never gonna be a problem
or I have so many cause it's never gonna
be an issue and then you introduce a
contended lock and now suddenly that
doesn't matter or you end up filling up
your bandwidth which causes the
increased latency which now means your
queues get full which now means thing
timeouts occur which now is that at that
cascading failure cascading failures
right so people talk about cascading
failures in the in the arena of things
like distributed application design and
services but the reality is even in the
in the context of a single process
running on one machine it's a mini
microcosm of of a distributed
application right there because you've
got CPU and you've got IO and you've got
memory and you've got shared resources
and any one problem any of those areas
can cause a problem in another as we'll
hopefully see awesome so that was the
Machine level resources so CPU memory
and i/o for the CR itself they're a
bunch of shared things so the GC you
know is shared across the shirt across
the entire application the thread pool
is shared across the entire application
so when you Costas usually a traveler GC
it affects the entire application so for
example if you experience our trebla
starvation your timers won't fire
because the timer uses the triple as
well see you and I'm game these
cascading events where if one something
goes down the entire app we get to fail
horribly right
errors are very expensive if you turn it
exception as to what the entire stock
that is a super sense of operation see
donor threats actions very often locks
that are very hot I will see a demo of
that in the app as we go along and sync
io is kind of another thing that affects
scale and sometimes these things are in
your app yep sometimes these things are
in the framework or in the core effects
itself and then people log bugs because
we find places we didn't realize how
they contended lock or was doing
synchronous i/o or etc etc etc so and as
David said GC and thread Paul are kind
of intrinsic so you don't really get to
control those they're shared and they're
in the platform you can impact what they
do because typically they're only doing
work because you did work in your
application but you kind of have to work
within the bounds of what those things
can do you have to understand what they
do in order to make sure you don't
overuse them so it was a fun example of
a service that went down I can't see
which one went down myself that went
down because of calls to string that in
turn in turn is a lock inside the CLR
a single lock across the entire process
so guess what happened request came in
she can happen and it took the entire
site them because it was blocking that
on that lock with a superhot lock async
programming does anyone here use async
await daily in their lives everyone good
most people yeah it's good it's good to
use it if you use it incorrectly it's
really bad
so the still using it correctly can give
you like masses feel improvement
use it in crap you can actually make it
worse than it was before you change the
async in the first place yeah dona has a
bunch of async traps mostly because we
came from a synchronous world and you
get to add I think as a bolt-on so api's
kind of have sync and async api is and
they don't interact well together so
there's kind of a bunch of issues if you
use certain things in certain orders and
you'll see a bunch of those traps as we
go through talking in general the main
rule is just don't block purple thread I
may never just on one block ever and
what do we mean by block can you
elaborate to stop the threat from
running doing useful work
don't call tossed out wait toss not
result toss dot you'll see a bunch of
API said okay they shouldn't call okay
all right is anyone here do testing
before going to production touch no you
don't like it's not production is my
taste so usually what we see people run
a little under and the local machine
that their dev box they run like a B
with a hundred connections and then
that's good and then they put in
production and it falls over at some
point right
mature team is why I've seen them do is
they run a bunch of skill tests figure
out the limits of each of their skill
units and then put in like hard limits
that feel aggressively if you go over
that limit so for example the the sky
team they run out they run us our skill
tests and they'll find the mass number
of concurrent nations that they can
handle for any machine and they'll put a
number saying we can only handle 200 for
this machine that's to deploy so you
should have a fix see if you CPU and
memory usage for any RPS that's how you
would go about testing of a certain
hostile well yeah right for your
workload one one issue we see people ask
us know how well this blast scale and we
always go you should try it yourself on
your hardware in your environment to
make sure that you understand for your
specific scenario how you're the
workflow so if that was your question at
the end of this talk you would come up
with a so David that was a great talk
can you tell me how my application will
scale the answer is always no no we
can't like you need to try it yourself
there are so many variables that will
never or how does signal our scale we
used to get that one these never right
because it scales really well in the our
tests I don't know what's gonna do in
yours it really really you really need
to learn how to do that test in yourself
and some of the techniques you're gonna
learn today yep alright so the cycle is
you run a load test find a bottleneck
and fix issues and their various tools
you can use there's you should look at
the counters for every substituent on it
so the number of GCS happening
the number of threads allocated number
the CPU usage the memory usage and look
at those things to figure out where your
limits are for each scenario and the the
normal thing you do is you run a little
test you hit some RPS and you say okay
that's okay
and you run a profile to see why you're
never up yes if it's okay then you leave
it as that's your max and you can scale
it from there so let's move on
alright so CPU skill the checklist for
going through one more
before we move on from lo testing yep
I've always liked a differentiate
between load testing and stress testing
and so load testing I think is what I
would use this term to describe what
David is saying which is you're finding
what works well within you know someone
says really just we need to support X
number of RPS for this system more
transactions per second and you do some
load testing to figure out how many
resources you'll need great now you know
that you can handle what you were said
you're going to do stress testing is
figuring out what happens when you go
over that how is your system going to
behave when you give it more load than
what you designed it for or what you
know it can handle because the failure
modes are varied right how your system
will fail when you go beyond what you
think your capacity is will vary a
massively depending on where your scale
problem is the rest testing is a great
way to find that and there are different
types of loads and different types of
stresses that you can apply to your
system it could be more work because you
give it more requests it could be
constrained memory because you're in a
noisy neighbors situation where there's
more processors running on that same
machine it could be a failure of some
kind where you're running in a
containerized environment or are in some
type of cloud environment and you lose a
node and so now your lovely load balance
farm of 20 machines goes down to 19 and
if you are on the edge guess what the 19
now are going to have a lot more traffic
than it did before
etc etc etc so that's a little bit
different to load testing but it's super
important to understand how the
application will behave when you give it
too much all right do you want it to
fall flat on the floor or do you as
David said you want to have a knife and
maybe another part of the system that
goes oh I'm getting close let me just
fail everything or send it out somewhere
else when I get to that limit there's a
funny story I said I've seen people end
up having Auto scale turn on on some on
some address service and it's killing up
because of a bug in the user application
and then they're paying a ton of money
because the bug kind of amplified the
scale I was like oh you can't you can't
held it this much low so you need more
low so we're adding more more stealing
right and causes you to be to be worse
right it's kind of issue 2 interesting
thing to look at all right the checklist
for scalability so there there's added I
made three categories here like machine
CLR and application logic these aren't
the full list but it's kind of a
kind of what we think are common enough
that we've seen in applications I'm so
looking at CP usage in general to see
what you see we're at a thread pool the
number of work items and the number of
worker threads that are currently
allocated looking at the number of
collections gen 0 j 1 j 2 hot locked in
the process for app logic usually jason
handling just in pillars from from
incoming or outgoing or hot pastor CPU
or chatty io doing a lot of small writes
to the network is really bad for for cpu
performance for memory looking at memory
usage looking at number of threads
because these tread is a megabyte of
stack timers is a kind of a big one
we'll talk about going forward the GC
heap size themselves not not collections
but the heap size free generation
strings are super common in a genetical
applications they're strings everywhere
actually I think the most allocated
string the most allocating be seen it's
been a core obvious these are just our
strings and tons of them will get you in
tune as well yeah in the applications
and that's not I mean it's not so wrong
as HTTP is a text-based protocol and so
if you're parsing simple to the wire and
then you're sending text back more often
than not HTML or Jason and so you often
allocated a Nanette it's a string go see
that's what you use right and that's the
thing you will learn for the first so
yeah but you have to be careful and I've
seen a ton of code reading the entire
request into memory and logging it to a
logger which is fine that's quite common
it turns out fine anyone here logged
their entire requests and everyone log
in with the blogging system so anyway
and people want because they want
accountability they'd have traceability
that they're ordered ability all these
things now I have to log every single
request so ok that's gonna impact your
scale like you need to think really hard
about how you're gonna do that without
affecting both the throughput the
performance and the scalability security
and security yeah you're supposed to
this both disposable artists except for
a TV client that's kind of a common a
common source of resource leaks a thing
local is a this magical type that flows
flows implicit stay across anything
boundary I can leak actually pretty
badly I'm with a later on
all right io number of open follow
handles and sockets on the machine I've
been to a wash port on non-buddhist
machines you can look at the U limit of
the actual machine to see if you hit a
limit or not there are threads in the
CLR made from it from mostly socket IO
and file IO looking at HP client your
data is connections to make sure you're
disposing them follow stream is kind of
a dumpster fire of badness to do with a
thing I've actually go over why that is
in the as we get for examples buffering
is kind of why said with some small
writes and reads from the network all
right sink over a sink who remembers
this this blah blah sh t from last year
don't come to lost user Pollock or
watched it online okay alright there's
anyone dis in their applications yeah
do we want to deconstruct this so people
understand we have a synchronous entry
point there's no way sink there it's
just void returning there's no task and
then instantly we're gonna execute a
task this one's obviously made up - doc
delay but task doc delay is asynchronous
right it creates a timer gets put on the
queue and it'll call you back five
seconds ish from now and then you've
immediately put a dot weight on the end
so one thread is being blocked and then
when this fires at the end for how many
threads metal is for this how many's
happens you're gonna get you how many
threads to finish this app to run this
code any one one one I've seen a boat of
one we're gonna vote a - and here - any
other call any other votes just one at
least two okay so two or more from here
okay okay the answer obviously is it
depends but I would go with at least two
is the most correct at least two is
correct yeah so why it's so bad so sync
over a sink isn't is actually much worse
than just pure synchronous code because
it's sink sink hood just boss one thread
the calling thread stink over async
blocks the calling thread waiting on the
async operation to finish which was then
like n that call and resume that that
work so you block two threads rebus
incorporation if those threads happen to
be both thread pool threads you end up
having to queue more typos
to complete the work in the first place
right so you can have in a trap where
you're you're blocking threat blue
threads and then requiring more threads
to actually complete those operations so
you have an invest barrel and then if
work is keeps coming in because someone
keeps hitting f5 or the browser it will
recover uh-huh then it'll never recover
because you can't keep injecting threads
it's a finite resource the threat party
yeah the system wants to schedule more
work which requires more threads but the
car complete the work it already has
which it needs to schedule more threads
in order to complete so you can see how
that gets really bad really really
quickly the thread pool is basically an
unbonded queue so it will just keep
queueing work forever right I just won't
run right so we add four that are very
slow right - to prevent from over
scheduling and that's kind of the issues
with submission your first place because
you bought you block more threads and
then we inject more at a very slow rate
see you right through yourself with
bandwidth arm to work yes but that
assumes that the works gonna back off
yeah it's roll down on the assumption
the worst kind of back who's ever
tweaked the thread pool configuration
sighs come on who's read a blog post
we're gonna stack overflow and yeah and
they said I'll just change that one has
nothing to do with this right all max
threads does is you don't start out with
Max threads you start out with whatever
min threads is number of cores Oona's
you which is number the cause by default
and then if you ask for more work it
will just very quickly go oh you're not
up to max it just give you a new thread
but once you hit max it doesn't just
stop but it's very slow after that right
so a massive two stops it does max stop
seriously like max actually max is
really high buddy really okay I don't
believe it threads super high that's
great screenshot so it's two threads
it's at least two threads at least tasks
do this crazy trick where they basically
try to resume the sort of super Segway
if you wait on a task the the thing that
completes this task it'll always try to
only run on the same thread even if you
said you wanted it to dispatch somewhere
else it will say it'll ignore your code
and say I'll run it on this thread see
you and I'm not using three threads in
some in some cases so this is a typo
thread this is the main thread and it's
completing this work so you can resume
yes the app we just saw this was a
really
black so a program main on the left
signing at the bottom and then the timer
queue for the task delay on the bottom
right and this is where they're both
waiting on each other
yeah right make sense yep
all right let's demo a simple sink over
a sink demo let's see if we can do this
so happens this this tool reckoning goal
I've no idea where it came from
called Bombardier called mine Bitcoin
can you see this is it too small on me
beautiful
is that good science you can see in the
back yeah hey taxi
I didn't hear no so it's fine okay I
have this wonderful app that's some
architect wrote and I could take this
what yeah okay yeah so your architect
gave you this beautiful service and that
the old version had to get values method
of a synchronous but to be modern they
had to add a gate I guess they think so
this guy added and it has a super slow
Network all you can't this isn't this is
fake you get that you had a synchronous
method at the beginning get value or
slowly moving to a sink and there's a
period where you have boat you're
changing your code so you have this
guessing C so you see you modernize and
you adding a new method that's right and
you changed the attitude to maximize
method we use you're calling the acing
one from the synchronous one means our
result yeah anyone done this surely yep
admit I mean I've done it it's terrible
don't do it hang on why is it terrible
no judgment no judgment at all
okay so then J does come comes along and
calls the synchronous API is because
they have no idea that they're supposed
to call they think once right
so they called get values ought to list
just fine and this in this control
action we run this No
super-slow right to run five seconds at
least
perfect it's working so now I'm gonna
hit this thing with some load what the
host 5000 API values and see what
happens so let me hit with like 30
requests so uh one is HTTP and one is
HTTP I don't trust it it's all good
David doesn't trust HTTP on stage it's
Reno let's write this one out and that
should take a little bit it should take
some time super slow right five seconds
per requests 5 seconds per request
connections trying to complete how many
30 requests there Lucas okay
math math that much time yeah one RPS oh
my god this thing is super slow alright
so now let's figure out what went wrong
let us look at the two things I'm gonna
attach the debugger and try to catch
this in action often they hit a five set
of controller five and debugger and I'm
going to try to cheat I set a breakpoint
in the timer itself in the framework me
not be actually good though you buddy
there yeah maybe put it there the only
ever got a process dump on Windows never
gone to our process of getting a dump
early shipping it somewhere because it's
like 10 gigs and have to zip it up and
somewhere else
yeah it's terrible isn't it let's try
huh it does it does
maybe dispose
if that this keep it time give it time
give it time pause okay so I can look up
threads debug windows the Reds
everywhere see bunch of threads button
wait if anyone ever use pile of stacks
it's not too many hands okay you should
use this thing super useful
so give you this beautiful visual visual
view of all the threads in system and it
merges things that are the same stack so
you can see I have 14 threads blocked in
a TAS thought wait here this is kind of
one of the signs of annoying when you're
when you're in that case of doing single
racing where you see a tactile wait here
at the bottom this tag right so symptom
is the CPU isn't being used memory is
flat you have a high number of threads
and they're all blocked on some some
resource right so if you see those
things you probably aren't countering
sync over you think and you have an
issue they should fix how do I fix it
write better code oh okay yeah and okay
what if what if the issues in the
framework fella bug okay go close it now
has that ever happened it's funny
because I'm looking at this this sample
you did with tellers we had a code we
had code paths that were synchronous yep
and then we introduced async code paths
and then we made the old sync Power Co
pars called the new async code paths
with a dot wait because why would you
want to code paths just what reuse aim
and it reminds me that I believe there
were lots of places in various parts of
net that may or may not have done that I
don't believe that
No so the face would be to have the
synchronous one we actually synchronous
and do this right this would be seen
right but now I've got that's code
duplication duplication bug here and
that's in there too right right I want
to show looking at don't just just this
just in case no one has seen it before
so to get it dump of a running process
there there API is that you can actually
call to get a dump from a process but
I'll show you how to do it from task
magic because it's kind of convening
sometimes
assuming you have access to you can also
get it in in a drop so everything you
can true get a dump from there how many
dump check no details find the process
called dotnet at sea and then right
click create dump is then right here
look at that thing it'll create a file
in temp
you copy over to your you zip it up copy
over it's really big it's like the
entire address of the process so it's
super big so you want to zip it up and
put somewhere else and you can open it
up in a couple of tools that I will show
you today so the first one is good old
visual studio you can just take a dump
it's like capture it sounds I can just
add app sure it don't capture a dump
Andrew and drag it into vs and I get
this view the dump summary is anyone
ever use this this feature of yes yeah I
love this view it's great so I can do a
few things does this work in every skew
now wasn't there a time when this didn't
work and I've given a nice kick it was
for a while I think someone said that I
thought okay oops
you have to install the windows
development toolkit okay what developer
kit okay that's good advice and it
always runs out of memory whoa if you so
much do too much focus that's fine
use smaller machines with less memory
dump ours will be smaller have a smaller
process so dumps are extensive to the
version of the CLR the version the the
business of the process so it's it's
poor a bit 32-bit so if you want to
actually look at a dump on a different
machine that you took it on you have to
actually have the right version of the
CLR and the right version of Android
business to cut it which is something
that we're working on we'd like them a
lot so it's really hard job it's also oh
s specifically you can't take a dump on
this and copy it to us and look like
that doesn't work at all today yet we
have plans I'll show you some tools were
working on to to potentially make it
better to look at look at these things
like offline so I can debug with manage
only and I'm back in this debugger view
and I can't step because I'm debugging a
heap so I can't we Stephanie or
there's nobody to go it's a process
running I can still use threads like a
steel the threads so if you're in a
situation where your weird process is
kind of dying you can you can get a dump
and put it in vs and look and see what's
happening
open the treads window and here's a
different dump so it's 15 threads all
bottom weight so same views for
different kinds of things we saw offline
versus like light debugging this is how
many people didn't know that you could
like use half of the debug tools in
Visual Studio on static dump files from
the process okay Wow Wow okay good well
that was well worth it look at that for
that and you can click on the stack and
see variables if they're not like super
optimized away you can see some of them
now obviously yeah that's a good point
often you're taking these from
production where you did a release build
now if you deploy your PD B's then you
get a little bit more but some stuff
just gets optimized out at runtime the
jits does Jeff and it can't figure out
where it is not a stack anymore it's
gone it's what it's better than nothing
it's a lot better than nothing yeah I
will learn a little bit later that in
conjunction with dumps you can also use
tracing which can sometimes help you
fill in those gaps that you don't
otherwise get so alright so the dubbed
about yeah we'll find them yeah yep and
load the symbols but symbols will slowly
get you so far because if the jits up to
my stuff away it's gone yeah so so one
more thing I want to show is looking at
the heap itself it's like it's
constrained in a different different one
but things you can do here you can you
can debug the actual chord dump you can
actually look at memory so if you have a
leak for example you can debug my memory
and look around to see what's in memory
the objects all the routes so you can
this is nice sort by count if you have a
leak sort by size I mean that's a lot of
types you can see what things are being
held on through so I can look at for
example services Scripture that's funny
find a specific instance and look at the
roots here down here do people know why
that's useful if you want to figure out
why something is being held on - right
it's called being rooted
so we're gonna talk about leaks next
right yeah maybe this is in the actual
locker
okay so let's fix the bug first go let's
do what we should do and make this
where's my controller make this thing
asynchronous so I'll make it a sync
adding a task this tight list gnarly
isn't it task a batch means love I never
book strength which fix it yeah after me
this is sync I don't have to wait this
yeah should we take that is this gonna
be faster who thinks it'll be faster now
that we've removed the contention by
seconds some people think it'll be
faster everyone else is like I'm not
button man I don't know what's gonna
happen why it sticks very wise so same
load as before it's still super slow
it's the same speed there you go you
know why it's because scale isn't
performing so you don't get more
throughput it's still ticking
five seconds per per request right that
you haven't fixed anything you've made
it's out there there there aren't five
threads blocked but you still don't have
more throughput right so no theory could
handle more load Theory that's about
like all concurrent people I think the
first time I got zero RPS and I got six
so yes okay very good yes so okay that's
better
good it also doesn't use any thread so
if I were to debug this at this code
again running it like that's a good
point
I shouldn't see any threads if I can
debug in time we walked with 14 threads
that were blocked before yep they pause
butter they still hold on wasn't running
yeah see fast I'm get a five I'll go to
this thing hit again and pause like
threads whoa whoa super efficient okay
so when you go to a think you don't use
threads but the big downside the biggest
downside is that you can actually see
we're close running right so imagine you
had an async hang where you had an elbow
request to your back-end service that
bit every on for some reason for some
some lag right you can't look at it
interview bugger and see it because this
it there's only memory co-sign there's
not there's no code running right before
we basically had as many requests as we
had thread right running because they're
all blocked now we have lots of requests
running we have them in the same tools
because they're not using any threads
there will be memory for is memory
saying if we looked at your heap
snapshot you could maybe find types good
luck that represented the thread is
insanely hard oh sorry the requests okay
that sounds like a problem we see you
got more scale but you can't see the
actual things running anymore
great so you got trade-off right so I
can't see it is the problem in software
engineering nope we will fix that
shoulder yeah that's being worked on so
we want to actually support parallel I
think all of you call pilot aft where we
have the same windows parallel be sure
the actual async state machines in a
kind of a chain right of calls which is
really hard to do properly
who has this code in their application
some derivative anyway yet John's got it
yep my hands fine
it's okay it's banded what is fine
what's wrong with it is anyone what's
wrong that's good good luck good luck
miss it work there right try I mean you
can't not lock right it's a it this one
has to be thread safe it's gonna be used
in a way it's used in the modern service
because it is modern
it's modern actually yeah
that's being used in the webservice so
it has to be concurrency safe unlocking
is actually completely fine right they
want to lock the only issue is if you if
this becomes a super hot lock if you're
doing a play actually hot CPU work in
that in this creation phase off it could
be a bad thing
well I hike attention right at it you
could do that and it would brick on arm
so you can't run a raspberry party which
is which is fine but they double-check
locked luckily on x86 and they do on arm
because arm instructions can reorder but
you're fine you don't arm so you can
button not net does the right thing if
you use the right things you can do that
maybe concurrently yes yes that we go
that is one area that's right so apps
are very concurrent on the web
concurrent collections are a bad thing
to use in this case but we'll see why it
doesn't help in some cases all the time
right realm it's really hard to see
contention in basic ProFlowers some of
them show it like I'm Tracy's timeline
view and there's a plugin for for for
the gas called the concurrency
visualizer I can show you right here I'm
not sure to go for yes 2019 yet but
there's one for 2017 and 2015 and it
gives you a really pretty view of
looking out all the threads I'm not sure
if there's a picture here notice pretty
angel used to be one somewhere
utilization view on the left
Freud's view and you look on the on the
legs that way yeah oh threads of you yep
so give you this kind of view it shows
you all the threads in parallel and
tries to show you where Lux or happening
on the same thread so you could use this
tool to see if you had condition or not
some professors will show you that that
you're the betters contention on like
the lock call so but it's really hard to
look at it in a profile and see that you
have a hot lock not net framework I
think there's even a perf canter various
locks but there is a number of
contentions per second number of 18
watts per second but dotnet core doesn't
have perf counters yet yet yet
cheapish cheapish vats would say who's
the doctor net / architect let's say
that lots early not cheap but they're
free cheap if they're not offended for
the most they're not intended for a
normal front normal apps it's only for
super hyper so that where is it would be
expensive John asked the question are
uncontained o'clock still considered
cheap and the reality is generally
speaking yes unless you have an
incredibly hot path that is sensitive
and then it's worth the effort to try
and write your alarm code which is
really you shouldn't look real offer way
too hard to do when you use concurrent
concurrent collections you should know
which which opportunity lock and which
ones don't lock so for example um
concurrent action area dot triad it will
lock on that key if you get the count
lost the entire dictionary if you if you
if you get if lock free so knowing what
the column in what sedition is actually
super important right if you don't then
it may not be any better than we had
before with it with a global level
behind dictionary sorry and the lack of
observability just like you said makes
it harder cada so knowing ahead helps
but it's difficult to know and then if
you call certain beefy FBI is they may
hit a loss on your behalf so like stream
that in turn for example GDI a there's
been a lock in GDI since the beginning
of time we've always recommended this
not drawing not be used on servers like
if you look at the official
documentation it says do not use system
dot drawing in your system that web
application and it's really bad because
the locks aren't just in the CLR the
locks are like in the library wide yeah
GDI is a native component and so it has
its own logic so yeah you got to be
really careful sometimes all right let's
try to show this so this demo doesn't
warn you right now
it's really hard to show it's something
that I'm gonna show just the code and
kind of how the code would change it's a
bit of a leap of faith here because some
of these things can be hard to
demonstrate on a laptop there's a hard
one do you not open so I there's a
picture of me with a region on Twitter
this is the region okay it's trying to
just be a fate of CPU burnin algorithm
John to work and do work right okay so
here's the code there's a lock try get
if I go by Eddy
all right so let's run
a super simple purpose on the get by ID
controller get by you buddy call it that
service calls get my ID there's a hot
thing and then cashes it in the returns
at all you right
super simple C values 12 all right run
that run for 10 seconds give you some
numbers you can't see that rate need to
shrink this thing
what
oh come on fight it shut down made me
tattoo to crazy
did you kill it oh that's awesome
let's try this
let's get good number first so I can
show something so that runs should get
like 20,000 30,000 RPS my machine yep
perfect
let's with the lock right super fast
lock not held very long but striking for
a dictionary see it's better I'm gonna
call cache thought get her ID this is
the old code this isn't you could should
return this
so I guess is this faster no no no one's
willing to know yes after the first one
why is there faster okay
[Laughter]
I'll take you for now
so much drama yeah oh it's about
anything that's nice it's the same
because concurrent action area actually
so two reasons this is a bad / if that's
because it's the same is the same key
the whole time so it's all people in the
same thing so it's that being get hit
once ever for the test and it's actually
the whole time right the second thing is
concurrent action area actually locks on
the on the key so for the same key it's
the same as having the same like one one
giant lock rice it was only one key you
should see better he does if you hit
with different keys at the same time
unless those keys hacked to the same
thing bucket yeah but numbers have a
hash code that's themselves so it should
be the should be properly right what's
the other issue with this code I'm gonna
know one call it yet what's the other
problem this could I know I see it so we
fixed the we fix the lock contention
lock contention do we safely
what else is wrong with this code you
were to talk already
you see miss lights this is an unbounded
cache with like taking stuff from user
input that's even worse security hole
and a memory leak yeah at the same time
so how do you fix that one hi how do we
fix the unban no that's probably tell me
I fix it
hey hey are you fix it how do you think
that one when you hire a consultant hire
an architect
I remember go ahead I memory cache would
that help though just it's got a limit
on it does have something on it and it
has some cache semantics like it will
maybe clear itself all items maybe
sometimes does it some memory cache has
also sort of cash it has support from
this one I think it's a memory cache
memory cache the concrete type it has
support for I believe size limiting is
it in a different version image compact
and that's not her the item don't you
have to add items to it oh it's in the
options there you go yeah
sighs like this thing safe limit it's
not super useful to be honest is it any
worse slow if you're if you're if you're
saving things I can be counted like
bytes or strings or something of that
nature not for general objects because
it's hard to know what size of things
you're actually put into to deteriorate
right so it would work here for Strings
you could also limit the number of
entries in the cache itself but that is
it being super hard because I'm gonna
have to actually like figure out how to
do best to do this right if cast count
very than ten then like remove something
from there and keep doing that but then
you have to sing actually how about me
synchronized with you well they're at I
am those all this for me this is a
typing job that actually does alva that
doesn't help me yeah but nothing
internet okay so you could do it you can
do a count again which would take a lock
on all the buckets in the concurrent
dictionary then you maybe yeah see how
deep end again there's good and you get
packed is there seriously is there a
good open-source dotnet cache library
that anyone uses anyone built their own
you said I'm going one I know they exist
I've heard John's built one though they
have lot though yeah it's fine lots are
fine it's actually a really hard problem
yeah - right well yeah not lazy this off
system web had an in-memory cache that
was completely private and relied on
private things to work well that don't
miss dinner coy yet we're looking at
adding so like the problem that David
just said which is what you really want
to say is just add stuff to it and if it
gets too big flush stuff out right
that's what you want right but if you
add a random customer object how big is
it no way how do you calculate the size
look at all the tools we had to show you
to use to even like walk the heap after
you take a dump it to calculate the size
it's not straightforward today in net
the runtime itself knows better
it knows very well actually it does
really well but what tell us anything he
doesn't tell us yet but we're talking to
the runtime team to try and get them to
add an API that they're comfortable with
that would let you do this type of thing
so you could use a memory cache to add
entries and then have a positive victim
at some point it doesn't have this size
issue but it helps the fact that like
the cache would grow forever because it
would I think we started to kick things
out if it goes over a certain size right
way default it gets kind of wonky though
right like because you're in a multi
scale system with multiple heaps you
could have an object graph where objects
are sprayed all over different cores no
and that's not thing okay no rest breezy
I don't know that could happen mmhmm
yeah
who has this Gooden application yeah no
one I don't believe you yeah it's fine
no no judgment no judgment it just
allocates a giant string first and then
it turns into an object it's so easy
though yeah it is very easy
I blame James for that okay this API
takes a string last stream silly it got
easier yeah okay so this is this is all
fine allocate memory is very cheap like
doing a new object is actually super
cheap if you have too many things that
that lasts a long time and it can lead
to GC pauses if you allocate more than
85 kilobytes in a single allocation
it'll put it on the large object heap
which is it's kind of like the place for
obstacle to die and they aren't they it
could lead to leaks right so you want to
avoid that as best you can and the issue
with this code is that depending on the
size the request blade that you expect
you could end up creating a string on
the lot of the heap proper request right
it's really bad thing you can do just
let me demo some awesome code that does
the wrong thing does just decide great
slideway comment here so things like MVC
just do the right thing like if I like
model buying
in value providers they do the right
thing he's correct how can I do so
rather than doing Jason deserializing
myself from the request I should use the
framework what if you want control
though but if you want leave won't
control you have to accept that with
control kind of something well comes
responsibility that's not quite the
quote that's why but you know it's still
it's what it works it works all right so
we're gonna see some interesting
nothing's free and put it that way
how's that so to meet this one work API
I'm doing a post this is a great tool by
the way it's a post and I want to upload
this file file named kind of long is it
I'm body a - windows - green amd64 weird
names palm party or - optimized for
intel - first this file is pokemon i
might get sued for this not sure I'll
put the Pokemon I think that's good I
want send one request first to make sure
it's doing right thing
let me debug this call make sure we're
all fine before I hire me with like that
doesn't request five seconds
sure all right all right there we go is
pokemon nice all right that works all
right so is anyone ever used per view
I'm sorry really
on purpose okay so per view is a tool
that's written by the seal our architect
it's not very framed to use but is super
powerful it can actually it can pretty
much see everything I'm going on the OS
and in depth on that framework but it's
insanely hard to use but there's tons of
videos you can watch to figure how to
use it I have not watched any of them to
be honest I just figure it'll be asking
him on email in a rage like how do I use
this thing so I'm going to run this run
this here is the thing to upload the
file or the one request I'm gonna run
the app
and I'm going to look at perfume to
collect see you're supposed to press
this tab because the under here super
I've ads DC collect and GC only see what
it does then I'm going to run the perf
test and then go back here and say start
something tells me this you I wouldn't
pass all the accessibility tests that
Microsoft usually puts their software
through yeah it's pretty all the high
DPI tape pretty good alright
doesn't RPS it's done a stop collecting
though and perfect will be working it's
working super hard it's ready
alright let's see what did memory GC
stats and it it collects the entire
machine not just a prompt process so you
have to find your process in this HTML
page and allocated to gigabytes whoa
it's not bad a second you see pauses
large object heap allocations where is
it out large off the wazoo yeah so this
and but it had this RPS so maybe maybe
I'm fine let's try doing it differently
let's try using NBC's built-in built-in
it from body okay
from body
get rid of this and this should be was
it it's even easier to type good
let's call it after right that's right
again seems less micro-service II though
does it
I'm relying on a framework to do it all
for me yeah I don't know what's going on
let's collect again I'm gonna run this
thing first and then rush to collect
rush to say start and I preserve my
option it's a good tool oh I lost it did
it finish okay done it's much slower
though oh damn it but it's easier
working it's ready okay same thing in GC
stats sync over a sink okay
look at that allocated one gig just
under two gay : a gig is January the
other one
I mean I could have let that slide but I
would have I couldn't a straight face in
front of all these people again past
time is like minimal okay that that's
good no pause no past time it was like
1.3 seconds or something before a total
pause time yep yeah allocations are all
small nothing on the large object heap
but it's slower yeah so here's an
example of a trade up you can make where
the thing that is faster that's really
bad for memory so pick your poison
better RPS worst memory less latency at
some point it'll fall over I like boom
right but it's pretty good right yeah
okay you can't have everything
unfortunately all the time you can't
nope all right um fix ish okay who here
has this good navigation this is so
straight that's good this code is trying
to take a task that doesn't happen an
intrinsic cancellation behavior and
timeout the operation afterwards so you
take that task you take a second task as
did some timeout delay and then you race
both of them so when any sort of so if
the delay task finishes first throw an
exception otherwise return the actual
task anyone done this this is really
calming sense right super common right
it's almost this code is almost correct
almost correct for broken so timers and
dotnet are the thing called a timer Q
and timers are a linked list whenever
you call you know new timer it asks that
list of timers it's optimized for adding
and removing me actually running a timer
Kaba is from the thread pool that's why
if you have starvation cameras won't run
on time so you can actually get things
out a thing about having starvation in
your process each timer queue has a
giant lock and a non full framework it's
actually one cue for the whole process
so it's really bad
on course much better I mean this mean
the supposed timers I guess you can Moo
from the queue it's kind of my
pretty-pretty slave slave plea so this
is like dotnet core I had to sign a core
has one Whomper see Pete Whomper core
imagine I have two cores on that frame
where has one my time is yeah and that's
the queue okay when you call remove it
goes away
fires it goes away I'm Carter defaults
in the queue okay all right let me show
I have a I have a dump that'll show so I
won't actually debug the actual thing
but the app that I ran I ran this out
beforehand you know call us on the
external service and then timeout after
30 seconds all right to make sure it
never runs out never runs pop out under
the covers is doing exactly yes that did
before you know timers are a lot more
popular now than they were like prior to
dotnet for really once once tasks came
around and then with async await and it
became very easy to fire off async work
but you wanted that work to timeout you
either did it manually or there's now
intrinsic so you use poly or you use a
library an API in the framework and
it'll be doing this for you under the
covers
so my meds are created everywhere now
it's very very normal
I'm going to try putting into until
video studio and I'm gonna try a
debugging managed memory hope it doesn't
crash our fall over a lot of objects
that's the law oh five million I think
this thing crashes please don't crash
you've got RAM right uh-huh no hold the
RAM yep there we go super reliable ok
look at that thing Tamarack you timer
look at the individual timer entries in
the linked list so the reason this is
happening is because if the operation
finishes fast enough that the time out
kind of doesn't matter anymore it'll
still be in the queue because no one's
had to dispose the timer so you'll hang
around for that for that duration if I
keep doing that it just pull up forever
forever forever okay so at a time a leak
tymberlee ok so every every every time
the timer takes it'll be over
Alzheimer's and fire them in order ok so
it's a very inefficient so this gets
worse and worse
yes yeah it gets worse and worse ok so
the fix is to do this create a token
pass it into the actual time into the
delay and then if the thing that finish
was wasn't the delay task
cancel timer and this will actually stop
this would this would get out of the
actual timer queue and have it not leak
anymore
I for the bug after I found it I agree
I super agree so yes I agree it's so
common that it should be in the frame
because we did we find this because a
customer I found it you know is making
this talk so I we found it on a on a
test I think we wrote it for Castro okay
and the test was hanging oh this is what
the flaky test we saw a million times
that's right and I was like yeah we'd
have tests that would randomly fail yep
okay more fun dotnet I think traps what
is wrong here this looks fine right a
synchronous it's calling right it's
saying it looks all good
what's the issue I'll tell you what the
issue is so right it's just this type
actually buffers the data rights it's
when I call the right thing it stores it
in the buffer it's only if the buffer
has exceeded that that actually goes to
the stream so what is up happening here
is it buffers hello world because it's a
very small payload and then this bull
will wreck it synchronously to the
actual stream which is really bad or so
you think you're doing anything io turns
out you're not the fix is it's go flush
crazy right yeah so the problem was it
implicitly flushes the stream on this
boat after I've written and it does it
on a synchronous code path it's disposed
isn't disposed async coming in yeah
don't worry about Nate quarry okay but
this is the case for every single type
of streaming done it the buffers so
gzipstream file stream it's a cell
stream yeah Wow anything that's I mean
funny because we turned sync I off in a
snack Oreo and guess what happened
everything failed that's a good point
you know it's been a cool 302 help you
find these type of things I tried to get
it done in two Oh
I pushed and then too much stuff broke
so in a spinnaker three if anything goes
synchronous on the writing path I think
over a sink it will throw the request
will fail and it will say nope you tried
to do a sync operation in the async
context that has led to us finding a lot
of issues in the framework which is good
in people's libraries and what type of
stuff as well sorry see what else
sometimes you have to be really strict
in order to find the issues that you
want to weed out there's a pattern here
where you call getter add and the actual
thing you want to ask the
do in the in the callback is
asynchronous I've seen people do that
result there doesn't help this is
actually the same issue a sink over
async what you can do instead is store a
connection area of something to task of
blah then the issue is that you may end
up running this callback multiple times
because it runs it can run more than
once per key right right if you want to
stop that then you just do a lazy of oh
wow lazy of tasks of T and async lazy
you may I made a type to make it yes
less less generic okay and more lambdas
to make you make your brain explode yeah
yes that's pretty bad however handling
and that so much to fix that bug I send
me a poor request it's pretty common if
you want to cut to like some back-end
service that startup or in LA Leslie so
you have a factory that kind to a thing
in the user connection that does pub/sub
like Redis for example people do this in
the constructor oh who needs to write
asynchronous work in their constructor
yeah cuz you want to get the connection
is super early and there's no sink right
edit oops
there's no good fix here to be honest
yeah just change your life just don't do
it in the constructor yeah I mean I know
I just write I'm sorry there's no other
fix for that currently you have to react
attacked it to not do that okay you want
to show you a doc before the end yeah we
are going to work on all of this stuff
so the future enhancements we're so
David's working with a bunch of folks at
Microsoft to try and build a set of
tools where the command-line tools
Visual Studio features and analyzers to
help you find a lot of these things
while you're coding and then analyze
them after the fact as well obviously a
lot of the stuff here is difficult so
this is a bunch of guidance the Fowler's
been working on on his repo yeah yeah
for now Holly's been acquired diagnostic
scenarios I mean has a ton of father is
this crazy yeah so check that out for
what you saw today I use examples of
everything you saw today plus a whole
bunch of other stuff is yeah right cool
and with that we're done yep we're out
of time so thank you very much again
coming please check out that stuff
see you next time